hey how's it going my name is pullin a
pike
oh my god sake she's not even eating me
superhero for15 join us 3% chance of
winning
thanks thanks Mortal Kombat I appreciate
it I came all right let's get this over
with so done I'm so tired I just want to
win one match that's all I want in life
button mash and begin for it
the [ __ ] am i doing I don't know why I'm
just working that's the real person
oh my god this guy's [ __ ] what how do
i ah [ __ ]
now there comes to juggle I like my
health I got her I got a little of I
can't even English right now I'm so
happy look at this look at this black oh
wow nice one don't like it when you act
like a bit nice one box
not a slap oh god oh god please don't
let me it's gonna hurt
I kicked you all day oh [ __ ] jet jet jet
jet plan B plan B everyone oh I need
that for YouTube's god damn it I'm not
insured what a little [ __ ] am i right
don't hit me don't hurt me don't hurt me
I'll kick you okay don't please
I like my balls - how long is she gonna
go no no no no no no please
throw it again oh oh you're gonna [ __ ]
my potapovich nipple piercings hmm sorry
you can have it back that'll be $55.99
I'm containing this sweet euphoric
twelve-year-old inside me who just wants
to yell what a [ __ ] [ __ ] but I'm
gonna play it off cool and pretend that
I don't care already did yell though
goddammit good match that's the same one
think it is I don't think I'll win twice
she picking her Mane now or he we need
more players in this game
bet you weren't expecting that move
idiot oh god don't hurt me
I'm Swedish oh god what am i doing right
I need help gasps kick her in the leg
how did that work what ow
oh [ __ ] I needed that to hit Ali going
going for it Oh God oh my god I'm so
lucky
yeah I can't believe that worked
oh she's well pissed I would be do
something fine
[ __ ]
nice one do you see on my try hard right
now oh god I missed yes
taste this fist up your ass why my foot
I need that for like sticking urs the
[ __ ] are we doing [ __ ] how does that
work what he said move taste and ass up
your ass oh god no that would have been
so nice I'm [ __ ] tryharding my ass
off
Oh can't believe I be that [ __ ] ha ha
ha ah yes I don't even give a [ __ ] comes
this is a saddest video ever I'm so
tired I just need it Oh God
like more jesus [ __ ] christ oh man
I'm the best player in the [ __ ] world
Jesus Christ
you're Bruce have no idea oh my face is
melting of sweat and pure Mountain Dew
faces mmm this is good fun I'm enjoying
this said I'm on anyone my level who
played this game there Peter oh great
cool this [ __ ] outfit I've seen in my
life
wife the wit Airness complete [ __ ]
destruction of pills I need to get the
[ __ ] out of here
oh I got one round I don't give a [ __ ]
he's well pissed now I can tell bunny to
get out of here I can't take the corners
give me something man [ __ ] there it is
I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead
ah [ __ ]
yeah
Tokita wins I'm the best player in the
world oh that was [ __ ] nasty
did I say one single world I just [ __ ]
zoned out and I this real-life oh my god
this is why I love this game right
[ __ ] there
yes whoo
that was [ __ ] exciting bouquet Takeda
oh man
I hope your boys are enjoying this even
though I'm not talking that much but I
do see a lot of comments people saying
like I wish it would just be normal this
is me as normal as it [ __ ] gets oh I
don't [ __ ] like you for you [ __ ]
actually play against someone who's
who's my level and I [ __ ] destroy
that [ __ ] in the anus I'll slap you you
want slaps I think I can talk oh [ __ ] me
oh he got me like this
the ankles oh god I was gonna do that
move [ __ ] Oh God
I got him I got him I got him I got him
I got him yes
what nipple piercing oh thank God I
thought I was gonna nipple not to there
you go
[ __ ] it might be a good Christmas
ornament there you go
looks beautiful
complete an innocent that's fun I don't
know it's more fun even um they're a lot
better than me I still enjoy it if
they're as good as me and I lose then I
[ __ ] hate this game and I hope it
dies just I don't know my inner
twelve-year-old
is just exploding with this game I love
it 100%
this monologue is going nowhere I'm just
really [ __ ] tired fraction I had a
long day all right purse I had I have
long days - all right I need some
victory in video games as sad as it
sounds Tokita
I know my next if I'm gonna pick an
character that I want to learn the
combos and [ __ ] up the next one is gonna
be Jason for sure
you best want to see some magic Jason I
learned he never played him because I
haven't I think you have to buy him
which is kind of [ __ ] but he's so
[ __ ] bad-ass don't make it [ __ ] you
thanks
say map why I don't know why they keep
falling for this there you go you win
and it's smack in the ass and a smack in
the ass what's that a flawless Jesus
Christ I'm sorry man you're on YouTube
[ __ ] oh oh no I film that bro I got my
bag beautiful all right well that about
does it doesn't it I might say sick and
she's made for me so I don't want to
play too and I think that's a good way
it ended I don't know if you wanted me
to do more I I love this game so I'll
probably do it regardless but leave a
like and I'll see you breast the next
one as always stay awesome